let's start with the Super Bowl it was
noticed afterwards after the game that
Tom Brady and Robert Kraft the team
owner had an embrace on the field and
there was a lot of conjecture over
whether you know Brady and craft were
kissing on the lips people thought that
was a little strange they look like they
were about to both went in - they kind
of say something at the same time and I
believe that they have for sure kissed
on the lips at some point and that's
just you know that's that's a look a
long-term male friendship I'm not even
gonna fault him for that I'm just like
where was Papa John you know I mean you
win a Super Bowl you're looking around
for Papa and I don't that's because of
the scandal recently but Papa John's not
there and I think when you see someone
as successful as Tom Brady almost kiss
Robert Kraft on the mouth in front of
millions of people
you got to blame Gisele you know I mean
Giselle's not taking care of business
you know if you're if if your husband
needs a kiss you better give it to him
or else who's going to craft and it's
just like a no matter how hot someone is
no matter how many millions of dollars
she makes as a supermodel someone's sick
of her and it's her husband mmm when
when I was googling this to see the clip
because you know I hadn't watched it
wasn't watching TV at the time there was
also you love you'd love to talk about
that as if like you not doing your job
well here's something to brag there's
also a meme out there or a kind of a
picture which it turns out is
photoshopped but snoops comm had to do a
study of whether Brady and Belichick
kissed on the lips after the Super Bowl
- because someone kind of combined a
couple pictures calm they're from
snopes.com I don't know it's like snoops
web snoops website have conspiracy
theories because I don't know if you
remember there was a kind there's kind
of been a controversy over the years
that Bella Brady on his reality show you
know kisses his kids on the lips mhm and
people just thought that was strange and
then there's been Super Bowls where Tom
Brady and his dad you know kind of kiss
on the lips and they're just like a
family kiss on lips that's that's the
family way they do things and they they
say that's normal and lots of families
do that what's your point I don't know
that's surprising to me all of that that
I just said is surprising to me I think
love is love I'm all for it I I can't
that's like the one thing I can't fall
Brady for you know is it is it a form of
cheating on his wife
yes has he cheated in every aspect of
the game including pliability I think I
think pliability is cheating I think I
think that these were non kisses I think
he doesn't look like from that camera
angle okay looks like kisses they save
it for the showers
you know you got that champagne you're
gonna kiss in the shower it's a fact are
you telling me now I mean I didn't have
a lot of people are down there in the
locker room knowing how many would think
that way people that would come out
robber crest has it has a serious
girlfriend you know I think there would
be a problem for Phil it's Super Bowl
night fifty three guys on the toaster
fifty grads and the Patriots roster plus
trainers plus owners someone's kissing
in the shower
it's statistics in fact there's one good
thing that came out of the Super Bowl
besides the first male cheerleader
congratulations Los Angeles Rams to
perform in a Super Bowl would be whoever
kissed in the showers I think maybe
that's why I'm so mad this year because
of the Los Angeles Rams because I live
in Los Angeles everyone around LA has
just been head down yeah trying to
figure out what's going on it is the
dower it's a dour mood around the city
right now people have a hard time
recovering can we just please move on
okay story that I can get into that I
can sink my teeth into Liam Neeson got a
little hot water this week in an
interview promoting his upcoming movie
he said when looking for inspiration for
the role for the sort of rage that he
needed to feel he remembered back
decades ago when a friend of his was
raped and when that happened decades ago
he said for weeks he would go around on
looking for any black bastard and that's
using quotes his quotes to come out of a
pub and have a go at him about something
so that he could kill him yeah he wanted
to he would walk around black
neighborhoods our predominantly African
neighborhoods hoping that someone would
step to him so that he could kill the
man and as revenge for his friend's rape
and listen people a lot people are
calling him racist for this and he yeah
he came out today and clarified that he
was like I was kind of admitting my
racism and it like after walking around
for a couple of weeks but this in my
head I realized I'm wrong this is crazy
I shouldn't have said it but I'll say
this he said he was walking around with
like a bat essentially like I didn't
call it's a constant push yeah something
that I didn't understand what it was
akaash the the Irish and the Irish are
not known for their racism so this was
this really stood out I didn't need
someone say something this but I
remember just after college this is
probably right after you left Greg one
of one of my friends was raped by a half
Filipino half Italian man and for I
would say six months every night I would
just walk around with a can of mace and
a cigarette lighter trying to find
anyone who was half Italian half
Filipino
and I got to the point at the end of the
six months that I would just ask people
if they were part Italian in Filipino
and hope that someone would answer me in
the first person who answered me with a
gun a push right across the face but it
never happened I just love what what is
how do you how do you ask that
mm-hmm how do you ask how did you ask
that yes it's exactly the same as it is
in English
surprisingly the Filipino language is a
lazy language they pretty much just took
English and and and just used that for
the most part I just think it's like
really funny to be promoting a movie
where you drive a snowplow and kill
people that you would ever let this be
brought up but he brought it up no one
was like hey did you ever
your friends ever been raped and if so
who did it and how did you react if you
brought this up during a press tour for
a movie that I mean I don't unless the
only way this could have been funnier is
if it'd been like an animated movie that
he went into this for that I guess
listen he was a great guy everyone loves
him Izzy yes how do we know he's a great
guy
because you can't be around this
business for this long without horrible
stories coming out remember the time he
was on ESPN live and didn't know what
the hell they were talking about for
five minutes that was amazing do you
remember this Erica I don't oh my god
they asked him about like Tim Tebow he's
like we should start over like we're
live what do you think it's been Tebow
is like he might as well be speaking
speaking French to me right now and they
just there's no question they can ask
him I think he only knows soccer and
Irish soccer with that I mean but the
thing is okay he said it you're right he
did even initially say you know it
taught him a lesson basically after four
to five times of doing this he realized
like what the are you doing like
you shouldn't think like this but it's
insane that he thought that it's it's
insane that he thought that in first
place and I even wondered like is there
any chance he's just making up this
story to like be like a cool act early
story about motivation and then he found
himself like really trapped in a corner
that he couldn't get out of he also I
mean he was in his 20s early 20s at the
time when you're like stupid and make
mistakes very racist mistakes like like
I'm not even to get into what Erica
pulled in Atlanta but when you're in
your 20s you know you kind of you don't
get a pass but it's a little more
understand it wasn't like he was like no
no that was promoting Love Actually and
I decided to walk around looking for
black people no no you don't get a pass
on that that's like that's like the
people that are giving the pass on you
know the group of kids that you know
we're going after the Native American at
that rally I forget what that you know
what that with the name of those kids
are I mean this guy he was in his 20s he
should not be in your 20s walking around
with like a stick just wanting to beat
up some a black person it wasn't like he
was looking for this specific
who raped his friend he was just looking
for anyone yeah you don't get a pass but
but if you make it to your 70s and you
tell the story it's not like Oh with
this guy should be fired do you know I
mean like if those kids make it to 70
they're like you know I did a lot of
great things but one time I was at this
rally and I got in a Native Americans
face like I I agree with you 100% but I
think when you're he's like late 70s but
he's still making like action movies
about killing people with snow plows
still he just made the one I forgive him
and I'm gonna see the snow plow movie
[Music]
you